maybe
you know if you're going to start drag
the place you start is with yourself who
are you what's your objective with this
why do you want to do this you know drag
doesn't change who you're it actually
reveals who you are your kindness I like
a kind dragon because you got to
understand people who gravitate toward
drag are sweet sensitive souls who have
uncovered the mystery of our society
which is it's all a hoax our society is
a matrix it's a it's all an illusion
don't become bitter that's the biggest
challenge you'll have when you get into
drag I don't care if you are in the
backseat of a Trix car or fewer in
church of you on stage do not take your
shoes off do not take your wig off that
is my number one pet peeve and that is
the rule for life know that let the
church say Amen
don't spend so much time trying to get
people to like you it's really a waste
of time if you're a kind person if your
intention is kindness and love you have
nothing to worry about and you let your
tribe find you you find your tribe you
let your tribe find you but you can't
force it you know the best piece of
advice I've ever been given was given to
me by my 10th grade drama teacher I
think I was going to get expelled or
something was up but I was really
distraught he said to me rupaul my real
name don't take life too [ __ ]
seriously now of course then I didn't
know what he was talking about didn't
understand it but here 40 years later
you better believe I know what he's
talking about